in late 2014 an ebola outbreak created a
significant scare in Dallas Texas
misstatements on travel documents
misdiagnosis and other mistakes led to
two deaths and a number of lawsuits the
incident highlighted the fact that
despite more than 60 billion invested in
bioterrorism Readiness since 2002 the
United States government still struggled
to handle a small-scale viral outbreak
and was remarkably ill-prepared to
handle a mass contagion scenario
also when it came to media coverage
Health in the line was between a
well-informed public and mass Hysteria
in response to the Dallas events the
executive branch tapped into its top
secret black budget estimated to be 80
billion dollars per year and reallocated
significant funds to increase the
operational Readiness of the Strategic
Homeland division in turn the division
ramped up as covert Recruitment and
training activities